and now it's time for bumming reviews
and if Chester a bum
tonight's review twilight eclipse
greatest movie I've ever seen in my life
will you marry my spoilers he's sister
named Ben who's the greatest role model
I've ever seen in my life she abandons a
caring boyfriend or a boyfriend that
just stays at her ot Oh a through lose
herself in danger wait for the boy to
save her he said good until II told you
for no reason that means in everybody
else's problem and dozens of people are
dying because of her and she's like so
cray
anyway excited to be that good of a role
model but unfortunately I have real
problems I slept in a box of pudding
shake some white suburban I would you
hit some boyfriend's going after her but
I think in a field of flowers with her
boyfriend okay wait did you say yes yes
but I change it to no balls just like a
male always pressuring the female into
marriage wait brother boyfriend who's a
werewolf friends win her back
and he's like I know you love me will
you come back to me yes if you put on a
frigid Stern about the history of the
werewolves and it gives us what vampire
was hunting the werewolves and the wife
of one of the we're lost answer seven
the stomach so that blood would come out
to distract the vampire we the other
werewolves could kill her she's a cutter
arm or something why did you stab
yourself show me the planet because you
don't know to see Twilight to get magic
that requires thinking then I hate that
can't go to your high school graduation
and the speaker is like great choice you
thought about not knowing who you are
making mistakes because even more
possibilities open up to you when you're
very glad those words really some kid
wanna be married like I wanna have sex
with you
no okay let me get my clothes up wait
wait no I knew it you're gay it was
pretty obvious I can't believe my new
tech job I mean I won't have sex with
you until we're married
it's how I roll great so he's a
Christian vampire didn't see that one
coming
but it turns out this female vampire
running victorious out
why because she buries and her boyfriend
is dead hello my name is Victoria you
killed my boyfriend program today
Oh new board vampires to kill her so the
good vampires in the werewolves decide
to join forces to protect her dozens of
people died because she was pretentious
SC's like whatever great so we're old
boy the vampire boy decided to hide her
in the mountains but the werewolf has to
keep her warm because she forgot to wear
a coat that's right she forgot to wear a
coat in the coach in the mountains once
oh wait no because even a bot knows to
bring a coating to the outside so
Jerusalem really does have feelings for
the werewolf and she kisses him okay so
she walks back to the vampire in his
lake
mr. boy is like you think of yourself
what I'm going to do with a wife in that
story did sacrifice yourself no are you
kidding that will require caring I'm
just gonna cut my arm take this kind of
head Oh crazy so the fight is over
exactly the fact that this is this new
point throughout the history kill do we
have to yes honey
to show that Twilight is edgy if you go
to talk to Lacey's even there's no point
for it okay cool
so better decide she will marry the
vampire but the werewolf says you still
be waiting what good thing there's not a
mummy in this movie or else it'd be a
three-way plus one this is just insane
can I use it the bun Twilight bar but
they made the fans don't even want to
see that